la Ravine des Avirons c'est la MEC
réunionnaisee de l'escalade de bloc une
discipline qui se pratique sans cordes
ni rappel juste à la force des doigts et
à l'intelligence de l'enchaînement une
discipline très particulière chez nous
puisqu'elle se pratique sur basalt une
matière qui peut faire mal Rachid et
Thomas deux grimpeurs reconnus sur notre
î partagent avec nous cette passion
historiquement le bloc c'était la
préparation au départ c'était la
préparation à l'alpinisme c'est dire que
est à Fontaine Blau et euh le temple de
du bloc c'est Fontainebleau et à
Fontaine Bau les Parisiens ils allaient
s'entraîner sur du bloc pour préparer
leur expédition et en fait ce qu'il
faisait c'est que et c'est une école
technique qui n'a pas pareil une école
de force et de technique et c'est comme
quelqu'un qui fait du 100 m ou du 400 la
falaise ça serait plutôt le 400 m et le
bloc ça serait plutôt le S c'est c'est
c'est explosif et c'est c'est des c'est
des mouvements qui sont très courts mais
dans un la temp très court mais très
violent
faut savoir que ici à la Réunion il y a
des équipes d'ouvreurs qui viennent
ouvrir des blocs alors les blocs on
arrive devant un bloc et ce qu'on va
faire c'est que on va essayer d'imaginer
un passage voilà là on va se dire
tiensir un passage ici d'ailleurs hier
il il y a eu un passage de créé ici pour
la pour pour la finale et donc on
l'imagine et après on l'essaye alors on
l'essaye sans corde avec corde avec les
pades et et après le but c'est de le
réaliser sans
corde la roche est hyper abrasive et
elle fait super mal au doigt en fait on
a les doigts à la fin de la la journée
qui sont complètement usés et ce qui
fait que stratégiquement il vaut mieux
commencer par des trucs qui sont
abrasifs au début et à la fin on finit
par des trucs un peu plus dur qui sont
physiquement aussi durs hein mais mais
plus dou pour les
doigts c'est spécifique hein donc le le
le bloc hein c'est la de la force et de
la la précision la précision de
grimpe de la technicité il faut de la
technicité bien sûr
toujours à
droite plus donc l'esprit en fait c'est
vraiment de la FR grimpe où on est on
est pas obligé d'être sponsorisé on
arrive c'est une ambiance de copain
avant tout et voilà on se donne des
méthodes on se réuni entre nous on se
fixe un endroit pour aller grimper c'est
principalement dans l'Ouest nous qu'on
pratique donc à TR bassin colimçon dans
la ravine là où il y a également il y a
également des voies là et donc ici aux
Avirons donc donc voilà on se balade un
peu à droite et à gauche et on est un
peu plus un peu tous dans le même dans
le même niveau donc ça ça nous permet
aussi des d'avancer sur des projets
personnel sur certains blocs qui sont
qui sont assez assez durs ici on monte
làhaut on a de TR blocs assez dur à
faire làhaut normalement devrait les
sortir donc ouis assz assz
impressionnant aussi on y
va
h đ
h
đ